luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel i'm here with my whole family
and my sister here and we
are in isla murada in the florida keys
and we are going
fishing for invasive lying fish we're
gonna go spear fishing
in fact and we're going to catch clean
and cook up what we catch
good morning morning good morning
welcome to the key yeah luke jeff good
morning jeff good to meet you yeah you
got it excellent
all right here we are with forever young
spear fishing i've got captain jeff
and i've got tony young here and they
are going to take us out snorkeling
and looking for lionfish hey thomas you
excited
i haven't been spearfishing underwater
since i was a teenager and i absolutely
love it so i'm excited to get a chance
to do this again
and i've always wanted to spear lionfish
so this is
this is gonna be cool
[Music]
oh my goodness look how clear that is oh
look i can see fish right there see
we thought this would be the perfect
spot for you guys to hop in get your
gills wet
i'm about to jack up the light exposure
on my list
time to get the lady views
and this is how you lose 1.5 million
subscribers
right now because we're in a special
protected area only certain permit
holders can spare invasive lionfish
and that includes mr young so if we see
any lionfish here he's gonna spear him
but after we go and snorkel around here
let the kids have some fun we're gonna
go try some other places where i can get
a chance to spear some lionfish
yeah this is how we this is how we catch
the fish we stick your diaper down in
the reef and all the fish float to the
top
all right guys you ready
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you want to see a cleaner fish cleaning
a barracuda like six of them
whoa watch out for you have fun yeah i
swam with them i literally got close to
them and they didn't attack me they were
like
hello hey jacob did you have fun yeah
nathan do you need a pee yeah you know
how you pee in a wetsuit hell
you just pee your pants you ain't cool
unless you pee your pants maybe you guys
need to go pee
come on
everyone just beat their pants raise
your hand yay
i think it's time to go look for some
lionfish i want to go poke a fish
tell me you like the beanbag
so we had fun doing a little bit of
snorkeling now it's time to knuckle down
and do some serious
lionfish hunting now lionfish are an
invasive species from the
indian pacific ocean area so they're all
over from
southern japan to australia to the
philippines they've been
let loose here and they're just all over
they're an invasive species here
in the caribbean gulf of mexico area and
over in the mediterranean
so we're going to hunt the lionfish
using these three prong hawaiian spears
and they're really simple easy to use so
even i might be able to spear one
[Laughter]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
awesome
are you sad to be leaving this spot yeah
she will go to a new spot
[Music]
that's okay that's so cool
so
oh
i miss well i missed my first lionfish
all right we're just gonna go try
another spot
go try to poke another fish
oh
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
oh my goodness okay i dubbed down there
and i nicked him
and he took off to a separate coral head
and we're gonna see if we can't find him
over there
luckily these things don't run very far
i shot him again so we're gonna try to
get him
[Music]
foreign
okay i shot him a third time we got him
on the prongs
but you need to really work him out of
that hole and it's just too hard
so mr young is going to go down there
try to get him out of that hole
[Music]
woohoo
there he is got about six bullet holes
in him
and his spine's right there oh yeah yeah
[Music]
so
um
whoa nice shot
oh what a great trip even though we only
got two fish
i'm super jazzed because normally they
do this with scuba gear it's a real
challenge to
to get this snorkeling but we did it
oh i appreciate that thank you so much
that was such a great time
what was your favorite thing you saw
fish
i got to tell you the bottom looks
really far away when you're up there at
30 feet of water you're like dad you're
like
oh wow doing everything you can decide
we caught the lionfish now we're going
to show you how to clean them these are
a
venomous fish if you get stung by their
venomous spines
it hurts like a bee on steroids from
what i hear
it doesn't feel good so not in there
yeah so there's no spines here
no spines there do have one you can see
right there they've got oh i see they
got right like a catfish right there and
then a couple on the anal fin
okay and then everything up on their
door so all the dorsal fins
when you get stuck and that flush gets
pulled back the grooves are exposed and
the venom is able to leave the spine
gotcha so the longer the spine and the
farther it goes in the more venom can
get into your system
you ever been spined i have been stuck a
couple
how bad was it uh for me it's usually
not too bad i might have built up a
tolerance over time but for most people
you know if you get in your finger the
whole hand will swell up about twice the
size
oh hey manatee that's our buddy steve
hi steve he uh he now eats lionfish
carcasses
it's a flesh-eating manatee oh that's so
hardcore steve oh and there's a nurse
shark right there
so they all know our boat they're ready
for their dinner to fillet these what i
do is i just pull their pectoral fin
back
make a cut there and then i'll hold the
entire body of the fish
using just the tip of the knife going
very slow and careful
so you can see that whole time i'm just
basically keeping my hand in the same
position
yeah trying not to move very much and
that's oh that looks gorgeous that's the
prized meat that's why lionfish is so
delicious
and his skin's not too bad looks like
you can probably just fry it up and eat
the skin
you can yeah one piece hold on
look at that oh there he goes there he
goes
oh he just ate he just ate it that
manatee just ate
fish flesh so he'll eat his spines at
all like um you know they kind of
it just seems like they kind of chew on
i don't know if they're getting like the
moisture out of the fish or what they
are but
they seem to play with it for quite a
while nice and tight
okay all right now drop it right right
in front of steve
bless leaving manatee oh he's just
totally sucking that down
steve you're my favorite manatee ever
man thank you very much you're welcome
you're right thank you thank you it ate
a ton of meat but there you go
some little teeny tiny lionfish fillets
and we're going to take these home and
cook them up
is this a shirt yeah
yeah you like that it says forever young
spear fishing
we had such a blast this is one of the
best trips i've had in a long time i
really appreciate it yeah it was an
amazing trip thank you so much for
coming out with us listen if you guys
are in the florida keys
and you want to do spear fishing
snorkeling scuba diving
rod and reel fishing whatever check out
forever young charters
with tony and jeff here and they will
hook you up guys i'm going to put links
down in the
video description below their website
and social media accounts so check that
out
thank you thank you great having you
guys oh we had such a great time
after swimming in the salt water and all
the hot sun
ice cream sounded like the perfect thing
becca got key lime sorbet
and then melanie got a slice of key lime
pie
dipped in chocolate frozen on a stick
that hit the spot
way down
hey good morning guys
oh
i am walking gently i am walking
gingerly but i am walking
oh oh i'm gonna get some stuff to cook
up
that lionfish and i'm gonna get a little
extra seafood to go with it and we are
gonna have
a wonderful seafood lunch today all
right
we got island seafood market near pine
island here
and it really backs up right to the
marina
oh good fresh seafood
hey becca i've got something for you
who's got two thumbs and loves key lime
pie
this lady all right while the kids are
doing online school i'm gonna cook up
some lionfish
and some jumbo shrimp and some lane
snapper
and conch fritters it's we're gonna have
a great lunch
here i'm gonna show you some cool
recipes
we got some naked mango juice this
stuff's nice and thick
and we're gonna reduce it in a pot until
it becomes a wicked awesome
mango sauce
[Music]
okay
that's why tonight
[Music]
all right that's it all right we'll just
cool that sauce down it'll be ready in
just a few minutes
yes there's the lane snapper
coconut crusted lionfish and some prawns
looking nice good it's a lionfish
here mango sauce here
and we're just gonna go and drizzle that
on the coconut crusted fish and shrimp
with the lane snapper i fried it on the
bottom then finished it off in the oven
and it gives it that nice crunchy
texture on the bottom without making it
too heavy and greasy if you fry the
whole thing good
really good oh the conch footage with
mango chutney is good
would you rather try some of the
lionfish
melanie what do you think of the
lionfish oh it's really good it's all
good
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed this video as much as we enjoyed
filming it
if you want to see more videos from the
outdoor voice youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos
every saturday morning and don't forget
to check out our many playlists whether
it's camping
travel and adventure or catch and cook
videos thanks for watching
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
becca's living her best life here really
good